all right
hello hope you're all doing well out
there uh really excited to talk about
the border series
as many of you saw it was a six part
series down at the
texan mexican border rio grande valley
very interesting part of the country wow
that was uh that was a part of the
country i've never seen
it's got a very unique culture i loved
it
but the important story that's going on
right now the border obviously which
we're all interested in
wow what an eye-opener uh you know i
gotta say i gotta be
purely honest on this as a u.s citizen i
had very
very little understanding of the border
situation
and yeah you can read the news and talk
to people but until
until you really feel i guess it's like
anything in life uh
it really hit home so in this in this
video i want to talk to you guys i'm
just going to talk to you a little
little background here and then it's
your form i want to take your questions
i won't be able to take all your
questions
uh but just get a dialogue going
question and answer
about the border so i was reached out
by a woman named amanda and she she
doesn't now but she worked for
the united cajun navy and she said do
you uh
are you interested in doing a porter
story and this is one of those stories
where
it's really it's impossible to get into
unless you have
a contact of some sort and you know i
didn't know anyone down there
so i actually wasn't gonna do it my wife
and i were moving
and uh it was just bad timing and then
actually my wife said you know you got
to do this
it's such an important story so uh
made it happen flew down to texas to
mcallen
and then uh met up as many of you saw
with this guy named raul
who who lives there and he's on the
ground there and knows the situation
pretty well
so the goal is to get as many angles in
uh on the story you could see i in one
video i talked with a trafficker
another video we talked sort of about
the process of how migrants get through
once they're on the u.s side
another video was about the river uh i
didn't get all the stories i wanted
i gotta say like you know there are a
million angles to go in
you know i wanted that migrant story i
had it in the workings and it fell
through
uh you can also get the story completely
on the other side of the border of
what's going on
uh more of the cartel chains in
in the united states that's more of a
dangerous story to get but a very
important one
there's a million different ways to hit
this thing so i i want i want all of you
to keep in mind most of my audience
understands this that
you know i'm just trying to provide a
view in like i want to get you in
to someone's world and take that for
what it is
it doesn't mean it's the full story it
means it's a perspective
i tried my hardest to hit as many
perspectives as possible
and like all my content i was like yeah
i fell short i should have you know i
wish i got more
but that's what it was uh
let's go to some questions guys uh good
afternoon thank you guys hello from
india
yeah that's a really cool thing uh hello
to india a lot of the world is
interested
in this story i didn't think that would
be the case uh nova scotia
thanks for reaching out guys ukraine my
former
former uh homeland for four years
germany wow it's very international
uh cartel's governed mexico yeah it's in
it mexico is very much divided in the
sense that there are certain parts of
the country
where yeah the government has very
little
next to nothing uh of control and there
are other parts where it controls more
and those northern frontier zones well
that's that's cartel land
and now what's really going on is
because the green light
uh you know of of people getting over
basically
they signal this is they receive this as
a green light it's gonna their chances
are better now
than than the last administration so
that's increased business
these cartels are bankrolling they own
that
they own they own the mindset they own
the territory they own the uh
you know i didn't go deep on that side
but from what i've heard they own the
cops to some degree
uh so it's a very very dirty business
it's
that's why it's very hard stories
because you're you're hitting
this humanitarian story anyone seeing a
baby crying in a terrible
you know position is is a saddening
thing right like that we universally
feel that
and then you're seeing the other side of
the story it's it's a big business
and then there's another side of the
story it's a very dirty business
and there are many different parts many
different players
involved so i'm going to get into the
question guys i'm ranting on here
um okay anthony says
in some of the videos people said people
need to do it in the legal way
but the legal way is broken and takes
longer than maybe a person's lifespan
what should they do and that's anthony
that's like
my biggest problem maybe not the biggest
but one of the things i thought about
the most you're totally right
like to have a solution there's not a
one
one all solution to this thing but
you're right if if
i was below the border and i was in a
terrible position
in life and i had a chance to make it
better and i saw okay the legal way
means what it's going to take
i don't know 10 years maybe 20 years who
knows and there's there's no guarantee
in that
or life's short i'm going to get over
i'd be taking the second option so i get
it
it makes sense so the legal way i think
you bring up a great point
uh the legal way has to be addressed
and so i'm coming at this just so you
know everyone comes out these things
with their own perspectives i'm coming
at it from a perspective of being very
curious about the world
of traveling 85 countries of living in
four
of really trying to think through
geopolitics and
the social condition the human condition
and these things interest me that's why
i went there that's why i make these
videos
the oversimplified solution to that is
there needs to be policy where
we have a certain amount of people that
can come in and they need to be
done it needs to be done in a legal way
uh because like you're saying if it's if
the legal way doesn't really work then
what's the point of him trying that way
um but the cold hard truth the cold hard
reality is you need a certain
there's a cap of numbers it's just i've
seen it in too many parts of the world
where
you know italy's dealt with this problem
really bad where it's like
there's only so much a country can
absorb
right and so how do you set it in a way
where it's fair for the people living in
the country
and it's fair for the people coming into
the country because one of the problems
with right now with what's going on is
the people coming in
they got the open arms right people you
know the us is saying to a lot of them
especially if they're young
or mothers uh look come on in we got you
i mean that's the basically unwritten
written message and so you're going to
get housed and you're going to clothe
and hotel than the beginning
if if you have kobe you'll go to a hotel
if you're not you'll go to the catholic
charity
here's a bus ticket here's a plane
ticket
here's here's basically you're set up in
the beginning
if i'm thinking from that perspective as
the migrant i'm like
wow this is this is amazing especially
if i'm coming from a terrible situation
whoa this my life totally changed i'm
this is this is the best thing
that's ever happened the problem is
which i learned this is where this is
where it gets really difficult i thought
they're just sort of like
let in and and they're good no
they don't have work papers so legally
they can't work
right and so i i met a guy that um no i
didn't meet a guy it was a story through
another guy
uh that you know did this years ago and
he he got sent back after raising a
family in the states for 20 years
he got sent back
and so it's it's it's very cruel in a
way to
open arms provide resources in the
beginning at least
and then and then what because the
amnesty
unless amnesty goes through they're
going to have to go to their asylum
court hearing
roughly i think it's 70 and 20 20
72 percent of those got rejected
so if i'm if i'm a migrant coming in and
i realize okay my ch i went through that
hell i paid all that money
which it's a lot of money uh you know i
just got rejected
i mean 72.7 are getting rejected
why would i go to that i mean just as
common sense
unless you have a really strong asylum
case i guess it's
they're not the easiest things to prove
from from the lawyer that i talked to
in one of the videos so where do you
leave where do you live people that come
into the country that aren't legal for
the long run
and that's where it gets really sticky
right
uh hunter biden will help yeah i'm sure
he's right on it
okay uh finding work is no problem there
there's a whole shadow economy of cash
david ken says this
exactly you're right there there's
in in the us needs laborers
and there's a lot of people here um
there are a lot of jobs to be filled
anyone that's been around any any major
city these days it's like help wanted
everywhere
so yeah we need we need we need the work
for sure the workers uh
is okay good question i'm guessing
you're from israel i see
hebrew is it possible to cover such a
controversial issue without involving a
personal political
opinion no i don't think it is i really
tried my hardest to
to hit it splice it down the middle
as much as possible and i do want to say
opinions change i remember
when i was 20 durango colorado was
living there and there were these
there's this migrant family in the
archway to a grocery store it was cold
it was snowing
and i didn't know their legal status i
didn't really care to be honest and i
just
they needed help and so my friend and i
helped them
we brought them to a hotel and uh
you know brought food to their place for
a week and then
i don't know who took them away but
someone took them away they're friends
on the u.s side
and at 20 years old that's all i saw i
said here are some humans that need
need help that was my opinion at that
time
now after more experience in life in
seeing
um what stability is in a country
how important borders are how important
legality is
now i look at it differently so no you
you're always
going to have every bit of journalism
has an opinion i'm very open about this
i don't want
i don't want you guys or or anyone just
to like
just look at me as the the end-all
be-all like this is an angle in
my perspective i i try to be as fair as
possible but you
there's always going to be everyone sees
the world differently
how social number works for illegal
immigrants
vishnu social security here's a problem
it that in that system somewhat broken
so we all have uh for those who don't
know out of the us we have a social
security number it's sort of like a
government
id number and this is really important
for taxes or
what else do you need social driver's
license stuff like that
so every year when i do my taxes
someone claims me as a dependent
basically they're using my social
security number to get money and there's
a whole
there's a whole it's called a black
market that's just
scamming people's social security
numbers
uh that's a whole other topic that's
that's a video in the future um
potentially all right
uh you should learn from israel how
borders uh
should look like in the 21st century
that that's a whole nother video and
actually i'm
going to do a series in israel in in in
palestine
this year was supposed to be last year
i'm gonna do it okay daryl says what do
you think is the
potential solution daryl my
oversimplified
uh very much oversimplified potential
solution is
you know from what i've experienced in
the world uh
structure and rule of law is very
important and
you need to make a way for for for
migrants to to come in
in either it's temporary work permits
it's a pathway to citizenship
it's it's work permits for five years
you know a lot of people are just want
to just work and make money and go back
a lot want to completely leave their
lives behind and stay for good
so there's some hybrid system where
there's a legal way to do it
through ports of entry and then there's
a cap
really the reality is if you said open
border completely america like our
border protection
goes home they're done and
the announcement goes out to the world
hey just coming to the u.s the
the reality this isn't a political thing
it's just like
common sense and the reality is you'll
have uh
i would guess hundreds of millions of
people coming here
what country can absorb that no one so
that's not a solution it's an alter it's
it seems altruistic but actually it
it would uh make everyone's life hell
that's in the country
that's that that's in the states so you
need a legal structure to do it you need
a certain cap
and like as the point the person brought
up earlier is you need to be able
to uh do it so they're not waiting 10 20
years
now that's where it gets sticky you know
if someone's if there's a line of
millions
that want to do it you can only let so
many in and a lot of people are the
majority won't get in
law's border and nation state comes
first i agree
i agree i think it's uh look
a lot of people um we're all stuck in
our bubbles
that's just the fact you're you're in
your world there's a certain uh flow in
your life every day especially covid
we're more behind the digital world
not moving around as much i realized
well cove had brought my wife and my
back to the back to the states i was
making content in the world
but i've realized i knew very little
about the united states
and it's a massive country with so many
different cultures and so many different
varying ways of looking at life and it's
a beautiful thing i love that part about
about the united states uh
but if someone hasn't been out in
america
this last year or even those last five
years but especially this last
year we have some serious problems
serious problems uh homelessness is no
joke
especially in california my wife and i
just moved from california
we moved because it got so bad where i
did not feel comfortable with my wife
walking on the streets
in one of the most beautiful uh
you know world cities and
there are serious drug problems there
are serious homeless problems
now it's not always a problem with
resources towards going towards homeless
uh you know in san francisco they're
they're just dumb there's a whole uh
the homeless industrial complex it's
called roughly
70 000 goes for each tent each homeless
person
the big problem is mental health uh
you know there's a huge mental health
issue a lot of this has to do with drugs
uh broken family structures uh terrible
experiences in life
whatever it might be it's no joke
if this if these problems don't start
getting addressed
uh it's just going to turn into one of
those countries eventually
where you know you gain you gain in your
world and then
the outside of those gates really sucks
as
that's not the the beauty of the us is
it's it's
not like that and there's so many
countries that are like that there are
like
few spaces you can be and then outside
of that it's just
you know you're not going to want to be
hanging out there
so i forget the question thank you uh
felipe louis for the nice donation i'm
going to try to get all your live chats
i got to figure this out i've only done
this a couple times
um i see one that's there so felipe
thank you
um appreciate your effort and encourage
you to take on humanity's toughest
issues and reporting yeah
you're welcome thank you i mean it's
it's my curiosity i want to learn
and if i have uh you know you guys want
to go through that journey with me
and i can create a living out of it
which i've been able to do then wow it's
it's i finally found my dream dream job
so thank you for that i appreciate it
uh what's your favorite or
what's your favorite or safe state right
now as in uh
states in the us
look i've been in parts of the country
the us is in a weird place where
there's this under the auspice or the
the uh
this sort of ideology of uh
compassion uh
it is in a dangerous place as far as
defunding police and weakening police
forces
i'm going off topic for a second i'll
get back to these questions guys but
we moved out of san francisco because
i'm there there's a few things just
you can see that don't look good if
things if things took a turn for the
worst it would collapse very quickly in
a way i'm not saying san francisco is
collapsing at all but
demoralized police a loosening of law
a d.a that calls the criminals the
victims
you can steal up to 950 with no
consequences in san francisco you can go
to walgreens fill your bag with stuff
and leave
oh that's great because nobody gets
prosecuted so the cops gave up
uh society's not really backing them the
government's not really backing them
what's in it for them they're going to
get some viral video if they try to stop
someone stealing 950 bucks why why
bother
so if you if it sounds great like less
you know no cops no
no law enforcement in the world will be
better it's that's a very naive way of
looking at
how the world works because i've been
around the world and i've been in the
countries where the rule of law doesn't
work or the police are totally corrupt
and it sucks and so
san francisco not like i felt like it
was dangerous for me to walk the streets
it was like i don't see this code in a
good direction
one or two crazy viral videos and i can
this place is sort of setting up to be a
tinder box
uh never in a million years what i've
said
even a year ago i'm moving to florida
but there we go i'm moving to florida
and we're here so uh what's the best
state
okay i don't know if this is my end-all
be-all
but uh for here right now is great uh
it depends away from places where they
sort of incentivizing uh
lawlessness i think that's that's a good
strategy one of those states
all right uh johnny johnny knoxville
uh he went flying through here okay uh
we love your honesty peter
godspeed uh come visit north carolina
sometime i would love to go to north
carolina i've never been to the south
i'm now living i guess
i'm in south florida that's technically
the south but i heard the more south in
florida
you go the more north it is uh meaning
like more new yorkers here and whatnot
but yeah i'd love to go
i would love to go there and guys my
goal is
to be as honest and authentic as
possible and and sometimes
in transparency sometimes i don't always
get it right
uh i i see i'm seeking in every one of
these videos i'm seeking truth and
that's a moving target
and so a lot of the people that uh you
know come into my videos it's almost
like the the cast or the actors
right the actors and actresses that tell
the stories
not always what they say is something i
agree with but i let them speak and
the reason i let them speak and let it
be how it is going to be
is that's the only way it's like
literature
it's the only way you can get into
somebody else's head and see their
perspective
so that's my that's my mission for all
of you
is to get into other people's heads or
other people's worlds that you
potentially might might not get in on
your own
and see them through that perspective
i go for that every story
uh but it gets misrepresented sometimes
as people say everyone i'm i'm showing
is like
my uh i'm trying to push an agenda and
it's like nah
i mean yeah i mean some people i really
agree with what they say and i connect
with them
right and then that conversation is
gonna expand and
and maybe make a really good video
but honesty is number one
so thank you for that uh why do you
think there's such polarization in the
u.s now
okay plugging in this is daryl he's from
canada he's been a supporter since day
one
oh that's that's a whole uh that's a
little video series
darryl uh look i think
people are innately tribal uh
and there are a lot of forces at play
there's a natural polarization in
society as you can see through politics
but there's also an artificial uh move
right now
to to polarize america and so what you
see online
this is the crazy thing i'm trying to
figure out i don't have an exact answer
you see online
everyone's at each other's throat there
are these crazy racial divides this is
what you're seeing online
i get online and i go on the streets
i don't know i'm talking to everyone i
don't
i don't see like it's at such a smaller
percentage
of what is seen online
so there's the real divide which exists
for sure
and then there's this perceived divide
that i think is 10x in
the real divide on the streets so for
example i'm talking to democrats and
republicans all day long and it doesn't
matter who cares i talk to
i talk to black people i talk to asian
people i talk to whomever it's not an
issue at all
it flows pretty well and these are my
experiences that's all i can speak for
and but to finish up on
the polarization point the media i think
the media is
the most cancerous force in in our
society right now
and social media just amplifies all that
extremely so people live in their little
information silos
and that look as a creator that's the
business model that works
i want to make a lot of money i could
just go hardcore
right on this stuff or hardcore left on
this stuff
just double down go all in i will curate
an
audience that's very loyal to what i'm
doing because they i will feed them
exactly what they want every time
and that's how you really build uh
online really think so so to sort of cut
it in the middle i would say i'm sent
i used to think i was left then i
i consider my extreme extreme center
right now that's where i'm at
i mean i like some things from the left
some things from the right
but some issues that that's harder for
my audience because sometimes
they're going to agree with me and then
sometimes i might take something a
different way and they're not going to
agree with me
like i'll be in saudi arabia loving it
or iran loving it
and connecting very deeply with the
people but then i'll talk about
immigration and
i'll talk about how no everyone should
not be let in
and so uh the good question daryl
i i i think we're getting gained no i
don't think we're getting
we are getting gamed and they're also
look how do you weaken um the united
states going through the front door uh
with the military probably not a good
idea
uh going going and um chipping away
society from the inside
best strategy china's the master at it
so there you go
that's even this whole border issue
china has their hands in it
they want to see a weekend uh a weekend
usa it only benefits them
and i used to look at the world as okay
it's just like if everyone just chilled
their military out
it would be more peaceful and if america
just went to sleep then the world would
be a peaceful place
unfortunately it's game of thrones and
it's always been that way
powers want more power wealthy want more
wealth
and you know if the u.s uh loses his
hegemony then somebody fills the vacuum
and there's always that game being
played and so the u.s
is a declining power right china is a
rising power what's in china's interest
to make uh to weaken us from the inside
and so a lot of that
is also pushed by the ccp whole another
video series
but a good one okay i'm in vain maine
very safe
mark good point yeah you're up north
you're far from the border i grew up in
vermont
and uh i get it you're removed from
everything and so the lot what was the
fifth
video i talked with a rancher quote
unquote we were looking for
entry he wasn't a rancher who's a normal
retired guy living down there
and he was saying you know
he's not against immigration he's all
for legal
immigration because now on his property
there are migrants running through his
property at night
and on the other side of the street are
traffickers that are
under the control of the cartels picking
people up
and so when you have you've worked all
your life and you have your nice little
retirement
place and then the very basic and
maslow's pyramid that we all want is
safety and security when that gets
jeopardized
ocean not good and so
if you don't have that problem happening
to you i think it's easier
to uh you know maybe take a certain side
of this thing
you know oh we should let everyone
that's struggling in because
it's the right humanitarian thing to do
but if you personally all of a sudden
had
your kid you didn't want your kids to go
outside at night and they used to ride
bicycles in the street and now they can
no longer do that
you're going to be affected in a
different way like anything in life when
it hits home it's all different
so yeah in maine you might not feel
anything um
the interesting thing uh the interesting
thing now
is uh you know when i left mcallen texas
to
to dallas yeah it was dallas you have a
lot of migrants on the plane they have
little envelopes
that say uh you know i can't speak
english where's the terminal something
like that
uh you know the government the us
government's set up so it's not like
it's not like all the migrants are
staying on the border they're no they're
going everywhere in the country
everywhere um so if someone illegal
you know driving a car because they look
you know
how do you operate in america without a
in the us without a with a without
driving unless you're in one of the big
cities
if someone illegal hits you in a car
then maybe that will hit home more
i'm not trying to do the scare
fear-mongering stuff i'm really not
but that's an example whenever this
stuff hits home
i usually have a different opinion um
someone said ooh florida yeah i
understand florida's not utopia
i just i just want to be in a place
where um
you know i'm in a place right now where
my wife can walk around the street and
there's not a bunch of heroin needles
around and
there's not like some bum with the shirt
off and a hammer screaming
at full volume and society completely
looks the other way
seriously maslow's pyramid basic things
i understand florida's got some
dodgy stuff and high crime in certain
areas i'm not
calling it utopia but you know
happy wife happy life it was a
compromise all i do is work so i don't
really care where i'm at right now
uh no state income tax is a nice benefit
too
and the the the lockdowns that drove me
a little nuts in california actually a
lot nuts
um what do you think about okay gilded
king what do you think about this
this will cancel culture in the usa and
do you think china's partner
i think it's ridiculous it's very
immature it's like what are we in high
school again
it's unbelievable that it's infiltrated
our institutions our politicians
it's disgusting i think it will hit a
the pendulum will swing to a point
because it will start eating itself but
it's it's
it's ridiculous it's everything we're
not
um and china has a part in it yes
china's a part in everything
anything to weaken this place china has
a part in it that's for sure
um james thank you james i appreciate it
you seem to get flagged from either side
of the
political spectrum more than another for
your coverage
i can't ever i get called everything i
get i get called awoke
which i can't stand woke ideology more
than anything i get called woke and i
called it get called a trumper
and uh uh
i get it all on all sides it's pretty
funny
uh look people like to put you in a box
an
easy to understand category
uh you don't have to think much like my
content is not
clickbaity it's long form most people
that want
the quick trigger stuff aren't going to
even be watching my stuff thank god i
have a pretty good audience i'm actually
very fortunate
most people are very cool um
okay uh you mentioned the china trying
to china trying to weaken the us
where'd that go from the inside have you
heard about the ccp trying to infiltrate
u.s and university systems by stealing
research and
i've heard some of this i can't speak
credibly on it
they are not stupid uh i've uh
i spent time in china 15 years ago i
actually came in from kazakhstan this
xinjiang province
i love that province the uyghur people
were the coolest people
and those these are the i don't know
what's your what's your
education all of you on on china the
situation right now is i'm sure it's
varied but
it's it's terrible it's disgusting
what's going on right there
there right now um i haven't been to
china recently
so there's always the online approach to
the world and there's always the on the
ground i think most chinese people are
very cool and i'm not talking about the
people it's
ccp what you're talking about too
they're smart they think long term we're
all divided
look if we were united right now
it would be a threat to our politicians
it would be threat to the to the uh
the the very elite that control the
world and
be a threat to china so it's all in
their interest to keep us divided
it's pretty basic um
okay i got another uh live chat guys let
me just
figure out how to get this okay cool wes
thanks for what you covered down here in
south texas maybe
if you make another trip i can put you
in contact with ranchers thanks wes
uh if you don't mind hitting me up
because i'll probably this
message will go off uh into the ether
contact peter santaniello dot com and
that's for any of you if you got any
great ideas
i'm all about hearing them it's really
the people in the story that makes the
videos
i just have to access them so please
west
contact peter santaniello dot com i
would love to get a rancher's story
um does anyone all anyone has to do is
buy a politician
america is for sale sad it's disgusting
it's the truth
it's really i never cared about da's
before
or who the mayor was of a city or any of
this stuff
until this last year when it greatly
affected my day-to-day life and then i
realized how that works okay yeah that's
exactly buy these people off they change
policy
and uh like i said what i saw in san
francisco is
is it's it's going down the toilet uh
i'm sure we'll hit some bottom and come
around but currently it's
it's it's pretty weird i never thought
it would be like that in the us
uh
najkin thanks for the awesome videos
people don't forget to like the videos
okay
sure thank you i never say that i just
feel like if people like
they're gonna like but you're right i
think it's more effective to tell them
but uh peter santana 2024 no way no way
i would
you know it's like if you want to play
baseball
you have to what grab a bat uh you know
run to these certain bases and if you
play the game correctly
you you win i think politics is like
that
i think people some people go in with
good intentions but to play the game and
win
you got to play by the rules and those
rules are disgusting and i want to have
no part of them i think
you know if i'm searching for
authenticity and in honesty
in my work and i don't want to uh
urinate on my soul
uh i'll stay out of that but
there are a few good people in there i'm
just trying to think of some
there are a few that i'm sure thank you
hub world i appreciate it
uh off topic but i agree bless all the
truckers we couldn't survive without
them
true that james bless the truckers
i we drove across country those guys are
cool
uh i appreciate it that was the thing
too driving across the u.s
i haven't done that since 21 years old
very cool just
such a different country i realized how
lame i turned in a way
we were in um i think missouri and
i saw an advertisement for dairy queen
blizzard i'm like yeah i've done one of
those forever got to do that go into
this
blizzard player dairy queen there's a
lady with her hood up on her car
she started scrolling through her phone
i just
glanced at it and let you know and went
for my blizzard
some guy yells from the across the
parking lot are you okay ma'am do you
need any help
and he came over and i guess she did
need help and he started searching
things for on her phone
damn i you know that is not gonna happen
in in the san francisco bay area no way
and i get it cities are cities but this
was actually i think it was outside of
kansas city
and i'm like wow that's cool respect to
those people
and i gotta up my game so uh
i don't remember what the question was
but driving across country made me see
how how widely varied this place is and
how beautiful it is
despite all the negativity we get i
don't think i hit one pothole from
california to florida not one pothole
that's an amazing feat in itself
uh uh can you tell us how much you paid
your guide raul
nothing zero and i don't pay people
the second i pay people the the vibe the
energy
everything changes and i've had offers
people saying oh
i'll you know i'll take you into this
and they charge a certain amount and i
don't want to do that in any of my
videos
i will tell you i will tell you if i
take money but i never want to do that
i never want to do that because
look i'm looking for i'm looking to open
people my job is to open people up on
camera
like get them to to feel comfortable
like a camera is not even there that's
why i use a gopro it's just
you know that big it's not obtrusive
it's not a big dslr and someone's faced
it's not
a camera crew it's not lighting it's
just
keep it as low pro as possible and let
people open up
that's what i like in people's when
they're authentic and who they are
and so paying kills that one hundred
percent
uh it is it is uh where'd that go is
some went by here um
something about dividing us racial
divides is
in benefit i'm sorry i lost your comment
yeah exactly it's the best thing to do
it's a trigger point
it's uh it's highly effective
when i came back to the us and i saw the
blm signs everywhere in in vermont where
i grew up i was
i was i didn't even know much about the
group i started deep diving on the group
i'm like whoa
do you guys know who you're supporting
like i get it the statement
i actually made a video on it uh blm in
the widest state of amer
uh of america and uh
you know i'm understanding the statement
i'm a total agreeance with
i got that i'm down but i'm seeing the
three co-founders and what they believe
in and who they are and i'm like whoa
do you guys really know who you're
supporting i realized no one really knew
who they were supporting
that was unbelievable so it's it's uh
it's a great way to uh separate and
divide us yes i agree
um guild the king why do you think the
current president and many politicians
keep saying that the us is racist and
talking about white supremacy
again back to a point i made earlier
there there is racism here and there's
racism in every country
don't kid yourself on that if you think
there's no racism in the world
white supremacists they are here i've
never
met any personally but they there is
that movement
um but as far as a racist country
overall
comparing to the 85 countries i've been
to and the four i've lived in
it's one of the least racist places ie
meaning
i went out to this jazz club last night
it was it was all blacks i was white
there was no tension it was cool
uh every ethnicity every person from
every
background has risen to the top in this
country
uh a million millions and millions of
times is that there's so much evidence
out there you just have to look at what
you listen uh
to music who you see on tv what
politician you know what mayor is
from what background whatever it might
be
there is racism it needs to get better
versus when i was a kid
it's a million times better versus when
my parents grew up it's
you know i think they had separated
bathrooms back then it's going in the
right direction
i hate racism it's disgusting it's vile
i
i like treating people uh respect is
number one
and i really don't i like mlk mlk is
about color blindness it's about the
content not skin color
and so this whole race it really
irritates me coming back to the us
and seeing our politicians push us
because it does it weakens the
population and divides us
it's it's a very good tactic if we all
collectively looked at our politicians
right now and what they're doing
and actually uniformly said
most of your stuff is bs okay you're
getting paid by whom you're pushing what
policy because of why
they would all be under the heat instead
it's a much easier strategy
to constantly to beat down this racism
narrative to keep us divided it's very
triggering
it's effective again wherever you came
into work my conversation here
i'm not saying it doesn't exist i'm not
excusing any of it
but but tell me about uh racism in italy
okay or how about being um afghani in
iran
i mean this is this is where the actual
system is going to work differently like
the laws
uh it's not even a comparison with
so much of the world so a lot of these
people too have zero
exposure to the world now if i was the
like
the victim of some racism incident then
that's my
look at the world and there are some
pockets that i have not been to that
i've heard of
in the us and like some southern country
town where it's hardcore racist
and that's disgusting and shitty and i i
just haven't experienced
i've been in big cities and yeah you're
saying you have an experience because
you're white i got it i've been called
everything too
by the way making youtube videos is not
uh
leave one uh protected from every label
and name in the book
i love when i do a a a series on hasidic
jews and i get called a neo-nazi you
know it's just
a positive series about hasidic jews so
uh
it's it's a disgusting game and it
irritates the hell out of i mean i think
we'll wake up to it
as a country
uh rocky pac-man hi peter it's your old
high school friend
from burlington vermont keep up the
great work love your videos thank you
i don't know rocky pac-man i'm dying on
i don't know the name it's just
a youtube name but thank you
yeah it is rigged mike again is rigged
uh to keep us forever divided exactly
it's a disgusting game the problem in
in the us and we're going to get back to
the border in a second the problem is
the big the most of it is socioeconomic
if you go to any of these big major u.s
cities okay if i grew up
in a really bad part of oakland or
wherever it's like what are the chances
they're very limited
and so instead of addressing going the
deep dive which will take
generations of building up
um you know family units
of education of job placement now some
of this exists to some degree and i want
to discredit those people that are doing
that but
like we're talking at like focusing a
lot of energy towards us like
if we want to turn this neighborhood
around eventually right
we want people to have the skills not be
reliant on the government
to be able to realize who they want to
be in this world in life
right if you want to give them i totally
believe in like
giving people a chance level that
playing field now the outcome
that's up to them where they want to go
in life some people want to work hard
some people want to sit
on the couch that's their choice and
they're they're free to think however
they want to think but to bring up these
neighborhoods
they don't care they never they've never
really made a solid attempt at this
so it's easier just to point racism it's
just an easier
solution for for majority of our
politicians
they the end of the day they don't care
i've gotten very uh
cynical towards politicians um
any plans of returning to kiev ukraine
that's where i lived before for those
that don't know
no i mean we'll visit but we're back in
the we're back in the states we lived
there uh
lived there for four years great
experience and i suggest to anyone who
you know you're watching my videos
you know maybe you're far along in your
life and you have kids and you're stable
and you're settled down
but if you're younger and you have some
some options let's say get out into the
world i mean it makes a lot of these
topics
much easier to understand when you can
compare to something else
you know like when we have uh you know
our politicians
talking about systemic racism all day
long you believe it if you don't go
anywhere else
systemic means as in a system how a
system operates
and i'm i you know if there wasn't a
million examples again of people from
every background rising to the top in
this country in culture
i would start to believe it but
it's sort of a new argument if you look
at the evidence i mean how many of these
these mayors are saying this and what's
their background
this the mayor of san francisco she's
black
she's a woman she's the highest paid
mayor in the country
and complaining about this stuff all the
time it's like
yeah let's address it let's fix the
problems
like these you think you're addressing
it by just throwing money
go go walk down uh downtown san
francisco and not step on a pile of poop
or
uh i'm talking about the tenderloin the
worst area or some heroin needles
you think you're helping is that
compassionate no they're just gonna talk
about racism it's disgusting they don't
try to fix
problems this is the problem in itself
all right i'm going to get ranting on
this
another question another question um
where i was i selfish of getting ice
cream instead of helping
i get ice cream almost every day i'm
trying to think of what you're talking
about
sorry i don't have the answer for that i
buy people food all the time i buy meals
all the time i give money to
people it's maybe it looks selfish if i
bought ice cream in front of someone i'm
not i'm not sure exactly
um okay uh
thank you uh see uh cedar mountain magic
on norwegi from norway norwegian crohn's
voodoo heart due day right
isn't that how are you norwegian was
there many years ago
great country uh thanks for getting out
in the world see through the propaganda
in general asia
generalizations of your own country
thank you for making good
content i really appreciate that
look the only truth is through your own
eyes and so the only way to really
understand the situation is through
you know without any filters
you're watching my content that's one
filter at least right there's a filter
you're seeing it through my my
perspective the only thing way to really
understand it
is through your own but even that can
splinter a million days ways because who
did you talk to
where exactly were you whatever uh
but yeah looking for truth that's the
number one
and uh and trying to do it in an honest
way so
thank you thank you for seeing that
i think the usa where'd that go
i'm sorry guys these uh messages come
through and i click sometimes here we go
okay
i think the usa was birthed on racism
with african slavery thing but
but don't focus on it all the white men
was african
free yeah it was birthday i mean this
the history we all know it
um but look how far it's come i would
like to say look where it is now
compared to that
and look where it can be and i i i again
believe in
not critical race theory where
everything is about race but i believe
in color blindness i don't want to care
i don't care about someone's color when
i hire someone i don't care
about their gender or their color are
they fit for the job
do they have the skills that i need
this is what i care about the other
stuff it's ridiculous
i honestly think it's like high school
people that look at color and race all
the time
um who your friend is or what you do
or people are tribal and people are
going to connect through common
interests let's be real
so if i'm a cyclist and
everyone around me cycling is white then
i'm hanging out with them
if i want to go to a jazz place and all
the people are black there i'm hanging
out with them i really don't give a [ __ ]
it's
uh again okay i'm getting off topic you
guys are pulling me into this uh
topic that's very hot right now so
rightfully so
um avi
uh mehta great series peter could we
perhaps have one for the u.s canadian
border
and the inherent differences between the
north and the south
that would be a good video but it would
be uh it'd probably be pretty boring
right there's like
my mom sent me a picture she was up
there the other day she
she still lives in vermont and uh it's
just like
grass and like some signs
you know spaced out you can walk across
nobody's gonna do anything
uh and so yeah it could be
i could probably spin it a certain way
that would be in i hate that word spin
actually i could probably
uh find an interesting character or
make it a certain way that would be
interesting uh but good idea thank you
uh you sound like oh god where did i see
that
okay michael you sound like you love
conservative policies about hard work in
law and order
can you say you support conservatives
you moved from california to florida red
state
look i i uh i don't align with either
camp and most people don't like that
they want to put you in a category
i'm very conservative on yes you are um
i do believe in law and order because
i've seen what life is without it
and uh working hard yes
i i want to i want to be able to create
these videos with the least amount of
resistance
and if i fail it's my fault i mean i've
until i started working
very hard on these i didn't have much
success
uh it's sort of like a it's a natural
darwinian
filter and so yeah i do believe in hard
work
um why should something be given to
something if they didn't work for it
yeah so florida's a red state which
it is the governor's read but if in
south florida it's very
a lot of people don't understand this
it's very mixed up down here
it's a melting pot i love it it's uh
it's got the strong
latin feel to it it's got a lot of that
energy
it's got a huge black population it's
got a huge european population
it's really uh it's really all mixed up
so i wouldn't
consider it doesn't feel like a super
when i think of like really conservative
i don't
feel it here but yes i think there's a
balance here and that's what you need a
balance
you know california is just like all the
weight is on one wing
of that plane and when you have no
balance
people aren't competing and they just no
matter what they're going to vote
democrat
and you have what you have and most a
lot of people don't even see it it's a
to me it's a frog in a boiling pot of
water
and it's paradise and i love it uh it's
the most beautiful state that i've seen
but no that you think you need a balance
so
yeah talk about truckers i can't talk
about truckers for too long
um but i love truckers i said that said
that earlier
uh okay god is a spirit not black or
white yes
i agree
all lives matter i agree we all matter
uh bruce jenner don't know much about
him i saw his his video uh quite
interesting
uh detroit is international border city
with human trafficking not boring
detroit is on my list
and i want to do dearborn michigan to
get a good
um muslim story this summer that that's
a goal of mine
do the average people in us really care
about politics
uh i think people are very busy here
it's a busy life
there are many moving parts that's hard
to say average
uh look our politics are
are are curated now in such a way that
they're like dopamine it's like
candy it's like sugar it's like eating a
the chocolate cakes that i eat every day
it offers like a quick hit of something
and then it's like okay what's in that
right i don't
i don't really feel anything after this
that's healthy
uh and the way it's presented to us is
like that right
and i and i fall down these rabbit holes
too it's
it's uh but the average person really
political i think the average person is
quite
sane uh wants to get along wants a good
future for their kids wants to live a
better life
i think that's the average person
uh you're from uh stacy from dearborn
michigan born and raised okay stacy i
hope to get there this year
okay can i share my email address uh
contact
peter santaniello dot com
i just got this question how do i see us
in 10 years i can't answer that right
now that's going to be uh
that's going to be ours
yuma arizona yeah i know it you know
it's not just texas obviously as most of
you know it's it's california it's
arizona it's new mexico it's texas these
are the states with the
with the border and uh yeah i think
there's difference
there obviously different stories every
part you go
okay getting a lot of yuma people from
yuma okay guys as i look through the
comments here i've got to mention one
thing if you like this
this is a sweatshirt super comfortable
dries doesn't stretch out it's this
company i'm working with now i use these
t-shirts
in texas it's called cuts there's a link
below in the description 15 off they're
really sweet i've been looking for a
good t-shirt for two years finally found
it
i would not recommend something i didn't
totally believe in
love these shirts i wash them i can wash
them in a hotel
you know sink with soap they dry quick
they don't pill
these shirts are below in the link cuts
uh
they're spendier than your average
t-shirt but it's totally worth it
because they last
way longer and look much better in my
opinion
all right back to the question stacey uh
you sound moderate it's high
hard to find nowadays well isn't the
goal uh
isn't the goal to be rational and look
for truth
isn't that the goal to look for truth
you know
and that's that's looked as moderate i
guess these days
do you have a logo i have a logo and my
logo sucks
and i need to do a whole rebranding
uh i gotta that's actually on the two
news this week get a whole rebranding
going because i know my logo is terrible
okay besides the money why does mexico
let cartels run wild and control mexico
i think it's money i think that's the
answer right there money
follow the money it's not a new
statement just follow the money so with
the border let's get back to the border
i haven't even been talking about it uh
there's so much money being made and
anyone who's an opportunist
and in that line of work down there is
crushing it
and realize that realizing that this is
their moment
and this is the time to move the product
the product is the
are the people that's the cold hard
truth uh
and it cost a lot of money you know i
before i went on this
this um video shoot
you know i'm thinking like uh you know
what do they do just get over there
river like maybe families going across
on their own i didn't realize how much
influence the cartel had in all of this
they're basically cattle in the sense
that they're tagged
they get wrist bracelets and there's a
whole
migration path that happens with
different uh
different stash houses coyotes
traffickers and that's all in the
auspice of the cartels who
who own all of this so 35
i heard 35 to get over the river
reynolds in mexico to mcallen but then i
heard as low as
in the in the video i talked with the
trafficker uh
as low as 1500 from he was uh getting
mexicans over
that's an interesting thing what about
racism they're not letting
anybody but mexican they're not letting
mexicans in how
it's not funny but how interesting is
that like that mexicans are not
uh included in this whole
you know somewhat open border policy for
for children or or younger mothers or
whatnot
and it's men too i did see men i want to
say i can tell you what i saw this is
what i can tell you
i understand everyone especially the
more politicized
the story gets the more they're pushing
their views so from what i saw
a majority of women
uh children but there were some men
it would some people say that that men
are not let in that's bs there were men
and it's expensive and that's another
video i'd love to get how do they get
the money and some people
uh sell everything you know honduras
guatemala they're selling everything
their land
their homes everything uh
other people you wonder how because
because now we're talking central
america to get up
now you're talking nine thousand dollars
maybe maybe ten thousand dollars
it's a lot of money it's a lot of money
anywhere
uh so that we're in a space now where
everything is so politicized with our
media that
you you can't expect mainstream media to
do a deep dive on that away from
politics and just say let's just try to
find the truth here
what is like the video i did on the what
happens to migrants once they get over
the border in the united states
okay they go to the the donna processing
facility which were the former kids in
cages right
we've changed the name it's the same
stuff except more people
journalists are not allowed in right now
there's a gag
order on border protection
so how unbelievable is this that
this isn't a pro anyone
politically but under last
administration cameras could get in in
this administration cameras can't get in
so if we just act like something isn't
happening maybe
maybe it's not happening is that the
strategy it's unbelievable it's
disgusting we're all about a free press
we're all about
trying to under like let's there's this
crisis let's understand this crisis
better let's get the cameras in there
let's have a conversation
uh and just to cut it all off
is insanity and the fact that we don't
have journalism at least not much that
i've seen
and going in and like you you know what
outlet is going to ask these
the questions you know they're not going
to go down there and start poking in
hard on like what's going on with the
catholic charity how much money are they
getting from the federal government
where are all of these kids going if
they don't have family members
if some don't have family members in the
states this is like traditional
investigative journalism and that's not
me
guys i really want to make that clear i
i started doing travel vlogs and now the
curiosity has led me to this but to do
the deep dive that this situation needs
takes
resources takes a team takes
months where are they
very few people doing it
all right
the cartels are violent um
yeah it's just there's a lot of uh
look it's it sounds good to say
help everyone who's suffering it sounds
good and it's
and a lot of people are doing uh things
with great intentions
and also i want to say when you are
living
in a perspective for example if i'm
helping if my
one you know 80 of my waking hours are
helping kids
that are in terrible positions i'm going
to sympathize i'm going to empathize i'm
going to want
everything for them to have a better
life so that's the prism i'm looking at
the situation through
if i'm border protection and all of a
sudden my job was to stop people coming
over the border and now i have to help
all these people over the border
and they they look at me as like uh
no longer is someone enforcing the
border but someone that's decides to let
them in and not do anything and as a
border protection agent i know our
border patrol agent i know that right
down there
a half mile away there are sex
traffickers going through that i would
have been able to stop before
but now i can't what's my look at this
approach to this situation
if if if something happens in the united
states
in an illegal migrant is is the the
criminal in whatever that might be
i'm going to look at a certain way if i
hired
the illegal person and it's the best
person the warmest person in the world
that's kind and just wants to work for
their family i'm going to look at a
certain way
and we got to keep this all in
perspective the end of the day though
that's when the 30 thousand foot
view comes down and says this policy is
not sustainable this is
this how can you sustain this just let
in
whomever emboldened cartels
emboldened sex traffickers that's
insanity
you have to look at it from a have a
strategy from 30 000 feet up
there's going to be no one-off solution
this is not the solution though
thank you guys thank you goosebumps from
mumbai india
love your series thank you love mumbai
india that's a wild place
wow i've made videos on mumbai actually
uh
unbelievable place
okay uh something i've been asked a lot
i'm not seeing you here right now but
i've been
asked a lot like how why don't you just
fix the countries below here
you know you know there's corruption
there they're fleeing from
problems right i like that idea that
sounds nice
we can't even we can't even fix our own
situations right now
again travel to american cities uh
the what what the one of the wealthiest
cities go downtown in san francisco
right now
we have serious mental health problems
like
you're you're having some guests over
for dinner do you want
uh a complete mess on the floor
no food in the fridge complete disorder
no you need to clean your house up it's
a metaphor for what we're doing what now
like
if if america had its it all
put together perfectly right and this
isn't an anti-american
rant i'm more pro-american now than ever
before and i appreciate all the amazing
things here
it's easy to get on the anti-american
rant these days so many people doing it
it's click bait
gets people excited but we do have
serious problems if we want to look
ourselves in the face look at the mirror
go around any major u.s city and look at
those
we got to work on that so to just to
to open arms
to a situation that as i
mentioned earlier you're not even
setting up like a very clear path for
these people
because they're not most of them aren't
gonna pass through their asylum hearings
unless there's amnesty they'll never be
legal
what are you doing
all right how many hours do you put into
a youtube video uh p
trader says this it really depends some
of the videos uh
you probably see the ones that have more
editing to them and
whatnot i'm probably not the most
efficient editor it's tedious
uh it's a love hate to be honest i would
say
um 15 20 not 20 hours maybe maybe 20
hours of video
because what you don't see is i'm on
that rolling you know
uh video for a long period of time and
uh
you know say i get three hours of video
i got to get that down to 20 minutes and
then you have to
pick and choose and cut off you know
what cut off the fat basically and get
it to like the lean meat
and that's always a tough point i can
make it shorter which will probably make
it better more popular in the algorithm
and
do better because you know i'm gonna
click on a 12 minute video more than a
32 minute video
but then i want to tell the story more
it's it's it's always a battle to be
honest
okay
all right guys i'll answer a few more
questions here
our government created all these issues
yeah our government's responsible for a
lot of and it's not
one guy it's it's years of government
it's decades of government
and uh again if we were united
wow they would have the heat on them and
they'd have to act
in a way that would make sense and
please us
as a population the goal is for that not
to happen
right it's the reality
have i been to switzerland i lived in
switzerland back in 2002
loved it verbier if you want a country
that's
complete law and order that's
switzerland at least from what i saw
it's beautiful
it's nice it was almost too stiff for me
though i got to say living in
like the rules are so tight uh
maybe at this point in my life i would
be into that to be honest i'm getting a
little older
okay peter great border series uh
have i been to maine before
no i haven't no i have a long time ago
nice place
uh subscribers will watch 30 minute
videos thank you thank you yeah i never
know
i never know to be honest and um the
more
the the channel grows then i'm starting
to realize that so thank you
it's it's good to hear that i never know
the balance honestly i could make an
hour video or a two minute video
and uh getting it so it's entertaining
enough but not too boring
that's the that's the hard part uh moon
moon is from iran uh she's been a fan
for a long time
shout out to moon you're awesome been
great support uh
have any of the public and government
sectors reach out to you to provide
answers for the people
no i don't think i don't think they're
interested i mean look at the
administration now
i don't care who you voted for at all it
doesn't matter to me
uh i didn't vote last election i was so
pissed by the options that i didn't even
vote personally
uh you can judge on that i'm sure a lot
of people
will judge on that but that that was and
there are reasons for this i don't want
to make this video on that though
but um these i don't think
like what are they doing right now
honestly
it's just ignore ignore it i guess so no
they're not going to reach out to me
because i'm exposing it
you know no one in that administration
would reach out plus i'm also
rogue and you know independent and
renegade and that sort of goes against
the system
system to begin with like that's the
beauty of this time
we can do this and i say we because
without you guys
i'm not doing this like i've made a full
full commitment
to th this is my life and all i do is
work really to be honest
uh and i love it uh but
this would have existed 10 years ago and
so i as much as big tech is uh
under scrutiny and for for for rightful
reasons
right like they control the narrative of
our world
at the same time uh in those
it irritates me just as much as most
people
at the same time they're allowing people
like me to make a life out of this
and show a story independently
without any filters there's no i have no
overlord
there's no one funding me i'm not
working with it my wife helps out a
little bit
uh actually more than a little bit she
really helps out a lot
but that's it and these are the times
when never before did we have this in
history
so that's a positive to look at in this
and i was worried honestly about this
series getting cancelled or shadow
banned
it did really well in facebook actually
like one of the videos got almost i
think four million
on facebook facebook is doing much
better than youtube
very interesting but i was worried the
whole time about
that being a problem okay guys
um thank you for all the live chats i'm
trying to scroll through you all here
uh placo thank you placo appreciate it
um who threw the poop
you threw the poop welcome to onboard
thank you for being a member uh
coma dash love your videos the the irish
travel community in ireland would love
to make a great series nobody that has
covered i would love to get in ireland
that's that's a great one and i've been
to your country uh many years ago i
loved it
very cool uh reach out to me contact
petersantonello.com
uh stevie thank you
thank you for the the support the ten
dollars
guys i'm trying to i'm just scrolling
through at least trying to get to all of
you
and uh i think that's it okay cool
a couple more questions uh i wish i
could see you all personally like i wish
we were all in like a big
theater or something we could all you
know more of that human interaction that
we're all missing
at least i am uh but
the next best thing huh
you want to see on joe rogan parker that
would be a dream but he's
i think he does such an amazing thing
for society
all right
what's next okay sierra i'm gonna have
um
i shot a series on la before this border
series and then this border series came
up and so i
quickly moved on that and so la got
pushed behind so the next thing is la
i think you'll like some of these video
guys again i try to hit la from
different angles i did uh
one on a diamond dealer really
interesting business
unbelievable business and the diamond
district in in los angeles was a mind
blower i had no idea
so we actually even got the hundred
thousand dollar diamond
through this dealer and they all work
off like trade and bargaining like
trust there's a high trust in this in
this industry and then we went up to the
hollywood hills to like the very wealthy
person looking for them you know
buying the diamond really cool story i
got in with the uh
god i think this guy was crips i got
into south central l.a
i was in both territory bloods crips
sort of showing what it feels like there
i talked to some interesting people
uh in the projects hit rich
los angeles which is beverly hills bel
air
hollywood hills is it pacific palisades
unbelievable that world in there and i'm
like seeing it i'm trying to bring you
guys into this like
you could live in south central or in
bel air in your view on the world oh my
god it's it's two different universes
and and
both those people never cross to the
other universe
very rarely right and so their
perspective on the world
you start to see how you know hollywood
elites view the world if
when you when you observe the bubbles
that they're living in up there
it's pretty unbelievable so i got that
story what else i got a venice beach
story it's a little bit outdated now i
don't know if i'll post it
uh that was interesting
and uh iranian musician danny assadi
great guy
so these are um these are the next
videos coming up guys
uh la and then i have to figure out the
next series i want to get into native
americans i want to get into
appalachia i want to get into uh
dearborn michigan bunch of stuff any
ideas i'm always open to
all right couple more questions i'm just
shift shifting through here
a lot of a lot of good questions
tiger woods great golfer
thanks for all your work thanks guys i
really appreciate it i appreciate the
support
a lot of great messages through this
series uh
waiting for you in israel i can't wait
to go
elitist liberals or something else i
just think elitist people are something
else in general it's like they're
looking at uh
yeah it's a different world i went out
to uh palm beach here
in uh in florida it's beautiful it's
amazing but yeah it's
it's a different universe and you start
to realize the more i do this work the
more i realize is people aren't crossing
over into these other worlds
and if i wasn't doing this work how
would i i'd be doing something else and
i'd be in my world but
you start to see how different and mixed
up it is here
for sure
uh i'm in south phoenix i'm a single mom
this group is buying up house after
house in my neighborhood peter this is
beyond my reach i'm just a single mom
two boys and these guys
uh owning homes that's it's brutal right
like
yeah i don't know if now's the right
time to buy a home it seems so hot
right yeah
but yeah and who's looking over you
and who what what politicians are are
speaking up on your
behalf it's a complex situation and when
people
hear their lives are changing
dramatically in the sense of
safety and security like the man i
talked to on the border who has a home
there
or for example if if there's i don't
know if it's cartel you're referring to
buying up all the homes there's a direct
effect on our lives
it should be a conversation it shouldn't
just be like oh if you have the
conversation you don't you're not
humanitarian
that's it that's moronic it's
unbelievably
simplistic how i hear some politicians
talk about this issue it's just helping
it's just helping a few people no no
emboldening a cartel who sees
opportunity
making a ton of money for traffickers
sex slavery is that a problem think we
should talk about that maybe
do we want more of that happening in
this world than society
kids being rented because a kid gets
across is going to get a crowd kid's
going to get across are there dna checks
with the parents to see if it's actually
the kid of
parents no maybe maybe this should be
uh looked into a little deeper instead
of just
hey just come on come on in
and then well you're not gonna most
likely be legal anyway unless there's
amnesty
yeah i fee i feel you on that i'm not
looking for a home i'm actually renting
right now
but i feel you on that that's that's
frustrating and who's speaking in your
behalf
uh gregory your man on the street boots
on the ground style reporting is so
needed thank you for being a citizen
journalist
and going into the trenches to shine a
spotlight on the issues the medium on
thank you gregory it's honestly that's
what fuels me
like i wouldn't if there wasn't a
problem with this i wouldn't have a
space to work so it's almost like a
benefit for me like i can
i can do this stuff but it's it that's
honestly my fuel and angers me to an
extent that like
how is this border situation not being
covered by the mainstream it is a little
bit
all the major networks were down there a
month ago but the
the numbers are up more now than in 20
years
there are endless amounts of stories
there's endless amounts of
investigative journalism that needs to
happen there where is it
we just we're not going to talk about it
is that that's the solution let's just
not talk about it i guess
uh i'm not talking about any of you guys
i'm talking about what the major
networks or
politicians many of our networks and
many of our politicians right
or they're gonna hit it from one
direction again i tried a few different
angles and i didn't
nearly complete what i wanted to
complete
uh you know i wanted that migrant story
i wanted many other stories
but i really tried and i'm one man band
down there and how how are these
networks without their massive resources
and teens not hitting like yes you can
talk about the migrant story and the
person on the mexican side who's
suffering and came from a terrible
situation right
but shouldn't you if you're a journalist
also talk about uh the story of the
cartels
or in the sex traffickers and all of it
and hit it in how about the catholic
charity
uh getting money from the federal
government how much money are they
getting
why is it going through them and i'm not
saying it's bad i'm just saying like
what is the story how about our kids in
cages that were cages before but now
we're not labeling them cages
but it's the same thing except more of
it these facilities are expanding
at a rapid rate uh people that
you know they go through here here's
something crazy i don't know if you guys
saw this video i did about the actual
process on the usa
migrants come in three days uh detention
they're all packed in
packed in then the covet for three days
then the covet testing happens right
now negative they go to a hotel for
seven days paid for it by the us
government
paid paid for by u.s taxpayers
not government they don't pay for it
taxpayers pay for it
or if they're covet negative they're
going to the catholic charity catholic
charities finding family and if they
don't have family they find another
other people they can go that's a whole
other story that does
that needs investigative journalism and
i'm not gonna make claims here
i just don't know enough so i'm not
gonna i'm not gonna say what i heard
because i couldn't fact-check it um but
you have people going through the
catholic charity out into the country
now getting on planes in the u.s like
that you that we all get on
migrants and i'm not faulting them i
would be doing the same thing
but we're talking covent tests what so
you three days are packed in those high
covert rates
um because everyone's packed in and
they've been close in stash houses and
it's spreading
and then you're talking a test
immediately after sometimes cova doesn't
show up
for a long time i think more than more
than three days after you get it
and also uh the tests aren't always
reliable
and then you're putting on civilian
planes and civilian buses here's a crazy
story about buses i wanted to get into
the bus station in mcallen
because i'm curious i'm trying to see as
much as i could see so i would go down
there at night just to see what was
going on and
there was a guard outside the bus
station and there he it was roped off
like the entrance but it was full
and i i just walked in and i wasn't
gonna ask him anything i walked he said
stop sir stop i said why
he's like uh i'm like i want to get a
bus ticket obviously i didn't but i just
wanted to
see what it was like in there and he
said it's private
which was total bs it's not private it's
the city it's a central city bus station
with greyhound buses
in every bus going out of there i said
no it's not
private i want a greyhound bus ticket
you're denying me the right to have a
greyhound bus ticket
and then he obviously is not in the
right so he had to let me in
instead it's all migrants with all the
yellow packets
of where they're going in the country
and
so these buses are are filled with
migrant and i'm just saying the covet
like if we're
so hard on coven right this is
especially in california
this last year so draconian on all of
this stuff
shutting down businesses restricting
people from seeing each other if you're
following san francisco city guidelines
you there was a time i
it was like you couldn't see people
outside in a park
you know but you could have a dog sitter
in your home the most ridiculous stuff
ever
that you can imagine there was even a
guideline on how to have sex during
covet
seriously you you can't make this stuff
up but this is what the city was
spending its money on
uh we're going through that and then
all of a sudden we have people that are
not legal in this country just sort of
going everywhere in the country on
planes and even to florida even when i
flew into florida
from dallas there were migrants on the
planes
okay i'm not blaming any of them but do
you think that's a smart system
you think that doesn't deserve
journalism or a conversation
what world are we in i'm a travel
vlogger and i'm like
making these stories i could do them
better i know i could
but how was that
all right thank you gregory was it the
rant the rant
you gave me some money for it thank you
i know i get passionate about this i
think like a lot of you it's
it's it's a tough it's a multifaceted
very difficult
complex issue and when we have
leadership
that doesn't seem to really be
addressing it it's it's frustrating
uh because most of us most of us are
proud to be in this country most of us
uh love the us despite all of its
problems
again i love it more than i've ever
loved it before i appreciate it more
than ever
before there's a great thing here
despite all the news these days
this is a wonderful thing the
opportunity is here
people down on their luck yes but it's a
overall opportunity you're going to go
to italy
good luck you know where's the mass
of whatever industry you're talking
about it's an amazing thing where you
put all the animals from the zoo in one
cage and they start to get along
despite what the media tells us again it
gets along here better than
pretty much anywhere i've seen go to
europe
tell me how long tell tell me how well
uh different races integrate i'm not not
everywhere i'm saying but
as a general theme every arab i've
talked to
likes it better in the states than in
europe most of them have gone through
europe
lived there and a lot of them have gone
through here i've lived there and come
to the us
talk to the talk to the immigrants in
this country the vast majority
are very proud to be here there's a
reason there's a reason people are
risking their lives coming from the
border to get into the united states
it doesn't even hit the ground on some
people like
if it's so terrible in the u.s are you
going to risk your life and your kid's
life to get here
no of course not i mean that tells
everything where people move with their
feet in a way i'm a
i'm a migrant in the u.s u.s i moved
from one state to another
legally but like i moved with my feet
i said this is not working this system
is not working
and i don't see this going well for a
long time
i'm taking a choice to move to another
state
because that opportunity in that state
and how the things
look again i'm not saying florida's got
it all together i don't even really know
florida all i know is where i'm living
now
it's a place where my wife can walk
outside and there's not a bum
with the shirt off screaming at the top
of his lungs with a hammer in his hand
that's nice again how about we work on
that situation before we let
everybody in but what i'm saying is i
move for opportunity
people are moving here for opportunity
why because the opportunity is here
all right what about canada canada
i grew up near montreal i loved montreal
great city
uh canada now what i don't like about
canada is this draconian
um lockdown from the canadians i've
talked to
it's a nice country i haven't lived
there um
but for my prefer preferences personally
i like the
canada canada from what i've been told
is more peas in a pea pod and i'm going
to get this wrong and i'm going to piss
a lot of people off i'm oversimplifying
it's more european i'd say in that sense
i say the us is the place where
more than anywhere you can really and
it's not saying you can't do in canada
i'm not saying that
but i think there are more examples here
that you can really realize what you
want to be in the world
uh culturally accepted
and there's a big thing you can realize
who you want to be in in so much of the
world
uh but culturally accepted for example
in italy if i'm going to tell my italian
mom
i don't want to tell you mom my dad
wasn't tired but you know
i'm going to uh make youtube videos and
i don't know how i'm going to make money
i just believe it's going to work out
and don't worry i got this
yeah good luck for the vast majority
it's it's a cultural thing
and i'm not saying those restrictions
aren't here in in culture but
less so than anywhere that i've seen
the tests are not accurate so don't say
the test yeah i've heard a lot of the
tests
there are very much inaccurate i did
mention that but yeah
exactly uh what are you going to do oh
the one
though the man went to mo you finally
got through to me he's he's constantly
spamming every one of my videos
about uh being italian so moe i'm gonna
clear this up with you but i doubt
you're gonna believe me
i wasn't born in italy actually my dad
wasn't even born in italy
it's uh it's italian heritage i do have
an italian passport
uh that comes from uh what is it called
juror sangria it's like uh
it's like through blood uh
[Music]
but doing something on italy yes i'd
like to go to naples napoli is
fantastic uh great food
really cool culture that will happen
canada is lost
i don't know i haven't been there
i think there's probably a lot of great
things about canada my favorite rock
band from when i was a child is from
canada rush
out of toronto i'm dating myself i'm
dating yes thanks for the five dollars
okay thank you thank you oh
all right drew uh border series um it
was great thank you i appreciate it
hello from madrid i'm loving the
international uh people chiming in here
thank you guys
you know i was in europe you know if it
wasn't for uh the pandemic there's no
way i'd be doing this stuff in the us
it would have been out in the world
still for a long time but i'm actually
more happy
that i that this happened in the sense
that i'm making content here
i feel like there's a lot of stories
that need to be told in the us
you know growing up always always
interested in the rest of the world and
there's so much out there and i'm always
fascinated with
different cultures and different ways of
looking at the world and i still am
but for the first time i'm really
interested on all the subculture
and more of some of the problems and the
beauty and all the things of
of the us i see it differently for the
first time i gotta say
so that's where my content's leading me
and and i appreciate a lot of you your
patience of of going down the journey
with me because i know i'm not
totally in one category all the time i
think would if i just did u.s
work it would it would be more
predictable but the reason i'm
sort of all over the place is i got to
keep fresh in this stuff
if i just do the same thing all the time
uh if i just did border videos for the
next three years i would burn out i
would get bored
maybe not bored but i'd burn out and uh
so thanks for coming along the journey i
know my mind is you know i'm gonna next
video is gonna i think it's gonna be
about diamonds in los
angeles totally different than the
border uh
but that keeps me fresh and i get to
learn about what i'm interested in
learning about
have i been to poland yes josh dovidanya
nice country poland is a surprise
actually is much
nicer than i thought it would be this
last time i went a few summers ago
infrastructure was really good at least
what i saw and
pretty nice place is it possible to post
two videos a week
i get asked you know i'm i've been doing
two a week for this border series
because i felt it's so timely
uh but i'll go back to one a week for
sanity like all i've been doing is
working and i'm just me and
i've tried to outsource the editing it's
never worked
there's a lot of nuance there are a lot
of things that
could come across the right way if
they're cut at a certain point and i'm
trying to make it
no one can do what i'm doing and that
sounds like i'm controlling but
uh sort of like here's here's all the
colors to the paint
go go make the painting in my head and
it's i just haven't had the luck yet
with that
but maybe in the future if i do then it
could be more like two videos a week but
for now
now one a week
uh czech republic czech republic or
slovakia yes both countries
both very cool places
uh majori peter white man bringing
in a white immigrant wife denying racism
and denying brown immigrants
access you are more right-wing than you
acknowledge
in my observation full of hypocrisy see
they're
you know i i i have a thick skin now so
i'm not even gonna
react in an emotional way to that um
well my wife came in legally
so we went through a legal process
which is actually a process it's it's
money it's
uh a mound of paperwork like this
it's it's a lot
so if you're against me marrying someone
that
doesn't matter what race she is i've had
uh
partners from all different backgrounds
uh the one i've married uh we connected
the best and
we have the best relationship so she's
my wife
i feel everyone's allowed to marry who
they want to marry in life i don't care
who anyone wants to marry
and we did it legally she didn't come in
illegally if she did it would cost a lot
less money but then she'd be illegal
so if that's hypocrisy
i can't i can't tell you anything else
you can believe what you're gonna
believe i'm not trying to convince
anyone anything
you can you can watch my work and
completely disagree that's fine with me
i'm from sweden that's a cool country
love it took a boat from sweden to
finland it was
called the um viking line this is when i
drank and parted and it was uh
20 now it was a whole night of drinking
it was like 80s style glitter balls
people on the dance floor
and when i woke up in helsinki i think
that was the worst hangover of my life
i slept on a park bench that day i think
it was 25
many stories uh but sweden was great
okay how do you like to travel when in
the u.s and how many states do you try
to get in the usa i would like to travel
a lot of regions of the world
uh well i traveled a lot what started
all this actually is after high school
then i'm gonna wrap this up guys um
people
are still on so i'm keeping talking but
i'll probably wrap it up here
uh high school okay what happened high
school
i grew up in vermont i didn't
i had no pressure i actually thanked
them now no pressure from my parents to
go to college they didn't go to college
they didn't go to college
and i know what i was going to do
uh like if people were going to college
or the military
seeing or or working and i had like a
lawn business and my
my best friend and i saved up money his
dad had an old plumbing van
and we i think we had three thousand
dollars and we it was
17 18 years old left vermont we never
traveled growing up other than new york
city and montreal i knew nothing
you know outside of that grew up in
vermont and
got in this van and went west and uh
oh god that that changed everything and
that's what opened my eyes i couldn't
believe being in utah in the winter and
it was sunny it was just such a weird
concept i never experienced that
and then all the way to washington and
california
that just opened up everything so i saw
a lot of the us
when i was young on that trip i think
the majority of the states
uh so what was the question about going
to different states
yeah the american road trip is a great
thing it's just like it's like
just coming across the country felt
amazing to be honest
uh so i strongly suggest anyone that can
do that do it but then
get out of the country if you can you
know you
you when you get out of the country you
see yourself in your world as a
spectator you're no longer on the game
say football right you're no longer on
the field
playing football you're now in the
stands looking at the game from down
you're not you're not part of where you
go
and then in a way you're not part of
where you're from and you can observe
the world and life in a way you could
never do so before it's like if you
never
if you had one pair of shoes your whole
life and then you put on a different
pair you'd feel how the difference
between the two and the things you like
about one pair and things you dislike
about the other whatever
that's what traveling does so
i strongly suggest getting experience in
the country because
this country alone is like especially
now it feels like different countries in
a way
ah it is united more than people think
make it out to be but it
i mean the cultures and the vibes
even the foods you know can be very much
different
but get that international experience if
you can if you're curious about
knowing yourself better and
understanding the world better i just
think it gives you more tools in the
toolbox
and that's not to say if you don't have
that look everyone goes down a different
path
i didn't go to university right away i
dropped out after two years i can you
know i just
i went back i finished i got my degree
but my number one has always been
understanding the world better
and every bit of focus went into that so
it depends how passionate you are too
some people want to build a family in
their 20s
i respect anyone's choice what they want
to do um
get out there if you can though
and when you get out in the world if
you're american and and usa
which from your title seems like it uh
don't
try and try to get out of your comfort
zone a little bit try to don't just do
italy and in france
um stretch a little the best
experiences came from for me in
countries like the republic of georgia
or
tajikistan or
kyrgyzstan i mean india itself is like
uh
that's a whole different world and i
feel like everyone should
should wait tables in their lives and
for a little bit and go to india if you
really want to understand the human
condition
those are two great things to understand
it uh
again i'm not trying to be some um
this is how you got to live life i'm not
this is how i live life
but uh you know get out there a bit
into places that you might not feel
you know like home not like italy will
feel like home but it's easy it's easy
travel
western europe's easy travel
everyone has a risk threshold and a
comfort threshold and all of that that's
just natural i
i like to take calculated risk and i
like
discomfort and
i like comfort too but it depends
how you're wired i guess
i want to take a pilgrimage to israel
but i'm worried don't be worried what
are you worried about
uh what like uh
geopolitics uh security situation
you just gotta take calculated risk
we've been wired so hard
especially fear cells that's the number
one thing that sells
well no sex is probably the number one
thing that sells okay fear number two
uh sex and fear together that would
probably be the most
um effective messaging okay
fear cells it's crazy that in the usa
we're brought up
so many of us that the world is just
this dangerous
dangerous hard place and like
you just gotta look at statistics and
numbers
you know like just just analytically
look through things crime rates whatever
and you have to do deep dive but most of
the world is open
and free to travel if you have an
american passport
it's a it's a true blessing uh
you know western european canadian
pastor these are true blessings it's
like you've
been given a gift by birth just to
access a lot of the world
and so uh
there are places to avoid but places
like for example the middle east is it's
just like labeled as one thing in this
dangerous place
uh i don't know there are dangerous
places in the middle east for sure but
some middle eastern places are way safer
than
than a lot of places in the usa like
it's just the reality so so look into it
a little more before you make
worry too much is what i'm trying to say
peter did you grow up with any religious
background i grew up as a protestant
i i hated any um
i hated sunday school all that stuff i
goofed off i was a bad kid in that sense
not bad but just pushed the boundaries
when i could um so it's not like i was
passionately you know religious my
parents brought me there and they
weren't even very religious to be honest
i think they're trying to do the right
thing
but so technically protestant
but i believe in a god i believe in a
higher power
am i a devout protestant now maybe i
will be someday i don't know
i understand religion way better now
after living with a family actually my
first series on youtube
uh i lived with the ukrainian family who
were refugees from the war with russia
they their apartment was bombed out they
moved into the countryside into this
little house they had no money they had
nothing really but a strong unit and
that was grounded through religion
and the first morning i woke up they
were praying for 20 minutes no
30 minutes you know okay it's sunday
they're praying i got it
but no that was every day and i got in
on their prayers
not that i was like because of religion
but i wanted to join them and be part of
what they're doing and
look the father was a former drug drug
addict street fighter guy that had all
sorts of problems
they found religion got off the drugs
and alcohol
and had a very strong cohesive family
unit and that at that point i said
okay i see how this can work for them
and i respect it now before i was like
why would anyone read a book that you
know they're redwood trees in california
that are you know older than that bible
why would why would you take that
seriously even though it's full of great
stories
that make sense a lot of them make sense
uh
how could that be a possibility and it
was that experience that just flipped it
on in me and i'm like
i get it i mean there's all sorts of
darkness and organized religion we all
know that but
i get it how that can be a very
important tool for people
uh i don't use it as an important tool
right now but maybe one day i will i
don't know
so born protestant i wouldn't say i'm
very religious right now i pray at night
before i go to bed that's it
okay uh cyderman magic
i'm supposed to be in china studying
language now but right now students are
not allowed to enter so hopefully this
year ever been there yes i've been to
china
very interesting country and like the us
in a sense it's very mixed up where you
go
xinjiang province where i was in the
west
uyghur people they're not han chinese
either you know hong kong
you know it's under the auspice of china
uh totally different you know it's very
mixed up
insurance i think it'll be an
interesting experience for you go for it
when you can
okay i like that people in my church
dress up nice on sunday i'm way too
simple like that
yeah i think it's cool i respect it a
lot look
what we all need is uh community and
to feel part of something and i think
that's why a lot of these movements
whether that be white supremacy
or or antifa
why these are attractive to some people
more than the actual message is the
feeling of being part of something
and we're in a society now where like
it's it's more difficult i think than
ever because
maybe we're distancing internet or
a whole other factor of reasons
you know it's harder to be part of
something uh
that's why i get really i get religion
again it fills that need
like community meeting the same people
or some of the same people every week
uh feeling part of something having each
other's back
i don't have it right now you know i
just work i have my wife i have a few
friends and i work
i'll probably need to gravitate towards
something that has a little more
communal meaning
in the future i think kids do that for
people too from what i've heard
we got a puppy we're starting we're
starting step by step
okay guys i said a couple questions like
an hour
ago okay two more um
pete trader says turkey is a nice place
to travel but also safe in my view
good point i love turkey turkey's
fantastic i strongly recommend
you know those people in the states or
or canada they're like i want to get
into the world but i want to have it
you know england is easy it's english
it's
it's not hard or france or italy are
pretty easy countries to travel
i want to reach out a little further
culturally
you know to more exotic place let's say
turkey
turkey checks the box for me because
it's that blend between east and west
it's got the historical stuff it has
istanbul which is
my top three one of my top in my top
three
of cities in the world great world city
i've always felt safe there i think it's
a fairly safe safe country the
infrastructure is very good the buses
are the best buses i've been on
food is fantastic people are cool
i mean we were uh we were in this place
a couple years ago
and we're down near the beach and around
the corner there's a
a tomb from marcus aurelius i mean
you're always stumbling upon these like
these
relics of western history and you're
like
it's it's a stunning place so i agree
turkey is
is amazing
all right guys uh thanks so much for
coming on board
appreciate it uh the shirt i was talking
about earlier this this is
one of the things that supports my work
so if you need a shirt uh this is a
sweatshirt but i got great
they make really good t-shirts i've been
wearing all the time a link below
the name of the company is cuts 15 off
if you go through my link
and it's not that uh uyghur
uh chinese slave labor cotton
it's very important to me because i do
feel like
there's no way to avoid it completely
but we're all
indirectly responsible for a lot of
these
industries that are that are making
money off us
there's some things you can't avoid but
there's some things you can so
i wouldn't suggest something that i
didn't believe in this is a cut shirt
they're amazing thanks guys for coming
on board the stream and watching the
series
i'll have the playlist to the series
down below if you haven't seen it
and uh thanks for supporting my work uh
whether you you watch here you like you
donated whatever it is
much appreciated got a lot more stuff to
come this is a big year
i'm gonna try to go deeper into
into u.s subculture and uh deliver for
you
so thanks again you have a wonderful
sunday to those mothers out there happy
mother's day
until the next time see ya